the government's aim is to offer every
adult their first dose and two-thirds of
all adults both doses by July the 19th
our new terminal State bus can we hit
that Target well since December when the
program was started our vaccination
rollout has been very successful so far
79 of the adult population has been
vaccinated with a single dose and 57
with two older age groups are now well
covered with the numbers of crucial
second doses administered Rising each
day but the race is on to vaccinate
those younger groups amid rapidly Rising
cases would today the highest number of
infections seen since February our
calculations suggest that 10.7 million
adults still need their first vaccine
dose of these 9 million are under 40.
and the fisa vaccine will need to do
that heavy lifting as the AstraZeneca
vaccine isn't being offered to younger
age groups but with reports of squeezed
finds the supplies across the country
there may be an impact on the speed of
the rollouts data up to the 2nd of June
can show us what role defines the
vaccine has played so far in the rollout
in fact the majority of first doses
given in the UK have been AstraZeneca
with Pfizer making up around 37 so how
many Jabs do we need each day well in
the last seven days we've administered
an average of 458
600 Jabs per day in total but we need to
have around
464 500 each day to reach the
government's Target
meeting that Target all depends on the
speed of the rollout and the supply of
the vaccines and scientists say it isn't
impossible
it despisa vaccine is key for
vaccinating the under 40s and if there's
restrictions or limitations in the
supply of this vaccine
that might have a negative impact on on
achieving this target
on the other hand we also have the
moderna vaccine if they Supply the
Madonna vaccine can be increased that
could help in achieving this Target and
we even have the Cure vaccine which is
close to getting regulatory approval so
for the next four weeks to the 19th of
July the race really is on between our
vaccination program and the Delta
variance of covert 19.